hello my name is Caleb Denby and welcome
back to game review today on game review
we're gonna be looking at a game between
Vishy Anand and wang hao of course wang
count making an appearance in the
candidates tournament this year but this
game didn't go so well for him we'll see
how Vishy Anand tried to take him down
he played 1 d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 Knight c3
Bishop b4 we have the nimzo-indian and
then it's yet another great success for
my favorite line against the nihms oh
the f3
NIMS Oh everybody loves the f3 NIMS Oh
d5 from black is a fairly well respected
line you see a3 Bishop takes c3 B takes
c3 c5 C takes d5 and now unlike all
these morons taking back with the pawn
wang hao knows what's up he takes back
with the knight this is the way you want
to do it d takes c5 was played queen a5
is blacks response putting pressure on
the c3 pawn now efore from white and I'm
used to seeing this Knight f6 move but
this is actually the second most popular
way of playing for black well now it
shows the most popular way which is
bringing the knight back to e7 the ideas
are pretty similar regardless of which
line you play with Knight f6 you're
bringing this Knight to d7 and this
Knight to c6 with 97 you're actually
doing it the other way around it's a
little bit funny but 97 Bishop e3 white
and guards this c5 pawn and it's a
little bit of a mistake for black to
take on c3 actually white is very
comfortable playing King f2 here tucking
this King away behind this f3 pawn now
the black Queen is just a little bit
misplaced on c3 so instead of Queen
takes we see castles Queen b3 from white
now finally defends this pawn Queen c7
from black tux this Queen back on the c7
square still putting pressure and now
Bishop b5 from white this move takes
away some squares from the black pieces
but it turns out white plays this move
simply because there's no other good
Square for the bishop you don't really
want to come to d3 behind your pawns you
don't really want to come to C for
either where you might get hit with a
Knight a5 attack
so there should be five just the most
natural square night ec6 from black we
now see 92 from white we already see
kind of a battle for this d4 square now
native 5 does come through anyways
Queen B 4 and now II five from black so
this is kind of the freeing move that
black wants to play here this move
allows this bishop to jump out to the e6
square it also takes away some key
squares for white doesn't allow things
like 90 for Bishop d4 or even f4 to take
away more space white of course simply
completes development gets castled now
Bishop e6 does come through for black
and now the key move of the game this is
why black doesn't really play like this
quite so often you know Knight a5 kind
of sidelines this Knight a little bit
and he did spend a lot of time putting
it there if we count 1 2 3 4 5 moves
with this Knight so far in the game
we're only on move 15 and since black
has spent so much time moving this
Knight around and you'll notice black is
a little bit behind in development
actually and his pieces are much less
coordinated than the white pieces here
so what does that mean that means the
time is right for a killer sacrificial
blow
of course most sacrifices you see
involve capturing something in this case
though white simply does a critical move
which I was about to reveal but I wanted
to give you guys a chance to find into
home all right hopefully you see it it's
the positional sacrifice Knight d4
giving up this night for a single pawn
of course though this pawn is very very
important it's blacks only center pawn
and after black captures actually CC
takes d4 and White has a very powerful
very mobile pawn center and on top of
that he still has his two bishops and he
has total domination over the black
pieces and it turns out this is enough
for an advantage which is why you don't
see black spendings quite so much time
with this night when they play this line
these days
Knight d c6 does come on the board now I
see Queen c3 and now Knight d7 so black
once again
spending more time with the night the
idea though is simply to guard this d5
square now if white wanted to break
through with d5 we undoubtedly would see
Bishop takes d5 and Knight takes d5 so
this is the problem with giving up a
knight for so little material black
always has these chances to sacrifice
back now in the game white actually just
continued with rook FD one after ninety
seven but I did want to mention this
line has been tried a couple other times
by the black player and it may be might
be a better idea for black to play
Knight b3 the idea is you simply give up
this knight on d4 and try to play this
position there's only one game that I
could find in the database here between
a couple almost 2400 level players and
that game ended in a draw
although white did have a lot of
pressure throughout and perhaps he does
have a slight advantage so with that in
mind though Wang Hao chose 97 instead
just trying to keep this pieces for the
moment and corral these white pawns
white simply plays rook d1 now Rick now
d5 is threatened because he has more
support for it
so rook d8 renewing the defense of the
d5 square but white simply plays Bishop
f2 tucking this bishop away from any 95
a six is black's choice and this turns
out to be a pretty critical mistake much
better for black is to challenge this
center immediately with the move b6 now
you're kind of forcing White's hand to
do something if you just play something
like a four
well now you might get met with the move
a six Bishop a two and a B takes c5
could come on the board and you might
fracture the white pawns just a bit so
white does have to be very very careful
with how he plays and said though we did
see a six this Bishop does not retreat
instead Bishop g3 comes through taking
manage of this Bishop bullets here Queen
C is forced now this Bishop comes all
the way back to f1 where it's safe and
sound
b6 does come on the board for black now
we see rook b1 from White's Knight b3 to
cut off this rook from the attack of the
b6 pawn but white simply takes this
night and he's already regaining some
material here and now B takes d5 does
come on the board as I was showing in
the other line but here white has a key
move to keep the advantage there's
actually two moves that keep the
advantage but one move kind of just
delays this move for it for another turn
so let you in try and find the key idea
for white here to maintain the the
winning position of course that move is
not d takes e5 ruining your pawn
structure in fact that move as d5 simply
pushing past the C pawn keeping your
pawns nice and connected and getting
ready to launch these pawns further up
the board and this position is just dead
lost for black after ninety six you
really see the two bishops are just
incredibly powerful here guarding almost
all the squares in the Queen side Queen
b6 helps this Bishop out a little bit
black desperately tries to challenge the
center but we simply take this pawn
Queen d7 now Bishop b5 Queen f7 and
white actually captures on f5 after it
takes takes white now has three pawns
and two bishops for a night in a row
which is just a material advantage rook
c8 is played Queen d4 nice central
square supports the D pawn what's this
Queen is squares on both sides of the
board rook F d8 now a4 and black simply
resigned to this position understandably
as well cuz this is a very painful
position to try to play against the two
bishops on a wide-open board so that was
a very impressive game from Vishy Anand
Wang Hao I just got outplayed from the
opening and it it's a very instructive
way to show when your opponent wastes 5
out of 15 moves moving a knight around
sometimes it allows you some very
interesting some very creative ways to
play and this 94 idea is one worth
knowing sacrificing a piece to get a
mobile pawn Center is an idea that shows
up in more openings than just this one
for example I actually played a game
recently in the King's Indian that
featured this idea with a 95 sacrifice
so keep this one in your head maybe you
can play a beautiful sacrifice like that
and one of your
coming up soon thank you very much for
joining me today on game review my name
is Caleb Denby and I'll see you next
time